[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des Transports il
est 17 millions d'habitants du
territoire auvergnat et du Massif
central se désespère d'être les enfants
pauvres des mobilités de la République
au point que sur une carte isochrone de
la France Marseille se retrouve au nord
de Clermont-Ferrand en temps de trajet
vers Paris les ministres passent et les
trains sont toujours très en retard sur
la ligne Clermont Paris depuis de
nombreuses années et de manière
récurrente des incidents et des retards
importants pénalise fortement la
desserte de nos territoires Auvergnats
cette situation était déjà inadmissible
elle devient totalement incompréhensible
et révoltante les retards ont été
jusqu'à 17h oui 17 heures de retard en
juillet dernier Monsieur le Ministre
comment pouvez-vous venir sur notre
territoire et nous dire la même chose
mot pour mot que votre prédécesseur il a
trois ans sur le plan financier sur les
travaux tant attendus en effet des
améliorations nécessaires de la ligne
n'avance pas le calendrier n'est pas
respecté et pire vous exigez désormais
une étude environnemental qui retardera
encore les travaux de 2 ans alors qu'il
manque déjà 130 millions d'euros pour
l'électrification de la ligne alors
Monsieur le Ministre envisagez-vous de
respecter le calendrier initial et les
financements des travaux prévus pour